ja also Henry Kissinger hat ja mal
sinngemäß gesagt Amerika hat keine
Freunde oder Feinde Amerika hat
Interessen und ich glaube dass es
wirklich an der Zeit ist dass wir das
verstehen dass wir dieses naive Amerika
Bild das sind unsere Freunde dass wir
das dringend korrigieren und unsere
eigenen Interessen sehen und auch unsere
eigenen Interessen verteidigen weil es
sind nicht nur die Republikaner es ist
nicht nur Donald Trump der make America
great again betreibt sondern das macht
die beiden Administrationen ganz genauso
teilweise sogar noch brutaler als Trump
damals also beiden hat im August ein
Gesetz auf den Weg gebracht also in
Kraft gesetzt nachdem die amerikanische
Industrie 400 Milliarden Dollar
Subventionen bekommen soll und zwar
wirklich nur Hersteller in den USA also
eine klare Diskriminierung zum Beispiel
auch für deutsche europäische
Unternehmen die die USA beliefern der
Sinn ist es sollen Arbeitsplätze und
Industrie aus Europa nach den USA
verlagert werden das ist ja Sinn 400
Milliarden dafür beiden hat jetzt ein
jedes Mal eine Verschärfung auch der
china-sanktionen beschlossen also ein
ganz massiven Einschnitt in bestimmte
Branchen die in der Halbleiter in met
Halbleitern Arbeiten amerikanische
Produkte auch verbauen das betrifft auch
europäische Unternehmen de facto läuft
es darauf hinaus Europa von dem
chinesischen Markt abzuschneiden das ist
gerade für eine exportstarke Nation wie
Deutschland ein echtes Problem und wir
sollten begreifen auch die Russland
Sanktionen Schaden Europa mindestens
genauso sehr wie Russland eigentlich
sogar noch sehr viel mehr weil Russland
hat zurzeit sogar mehr Einnahmen als
vorher weil die Preise so explodiert
sind wir haben die hohen Energiekosten
und diese extrem hohen Energiekosten
haben für die USA natürlich ein
positiven Nebeneffekt unsere
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sinkt da Trump hat
sich immer erregt über die deutschen
Handelsüberschüsse und über die starke
deutsche Exportindustrie das Kapitel ist
bald erledigt wenn wir bei den jetzigen
Energiepreisen bleiben und ganz nebenbei
kann die USA so sogar ein großes
Geschäft Unternehmen nämlich für das
europäische Gas auch für die Belieferung
Deutschlands mit Gas mit teurem Gas also
das alles ist nicht in unserem Interesse
und deswegen glaube ich müssen wir uns
dringend darauf besinnen was hilft uns
was hilft unserer Volkswirtschaft was
ist für die Menschen hier in Deutschland
wichtig und ich finde das sollte schon
die Politik tatsächlich auch bestimmen
Herr Rehberg wie ist es mit unseren
eigenen Interessen macht die Politik
genug für uns selbst muss es vielleicht
sogar mehr heißen MC Germany great again
also die Vereinigten Staaten Amerikas
Freund zu haben und eigene Interessen zu
betreten darin sehe ich kein Widerspruch
überhaupt nicht und ich denke mal gerade
im Westen Deutschlands auch im Osten
muss man den Vereinigten Staaten dankbar
sein über 70 Jahre Frieden und Freiheit
in Europa und auch
wer den Wegbereiter zu Wiedervereinigung
es war nicht mal gezeche das waren die
Vereinigten Staaten unter anderem noch
Frankreich war der eher
ohne den wäre es wohl nicht gegangen
Entschuldigung ohne Michael Gorbatschow
und Helmut Kohl wärs auch nicht gegangen
und Oskar Lafontaine und Gerhard
Schröder haben da keinen großen Beitrag
an der Stelle geleistet ganz im
Gegenteil auch nochmal zu diesem
wirtschaftlichen Thema zurückzukommen ja
klar es gibt drei große Komponenten auf
die unser Wohlstand mitberührt das eine
ist wir haben jährlich zwischen 20 und
30 Milliarden Euro zu wenig in den
letzten Jahren ausgegeben für
Verteidigung Stichwort zwei Prozent
zielt zweitens das ist das billige
russische Gas und drittens Lieferketten
China darauf neben vielen anderen
Faktoren das sind drei Faktoren die man
schon mit dem Auge behalten sollte ja
auch das Argument Freiheit und Frieden
durchhandel anstatt Abschottung das
Argument gibt es auch ganz schwieriges
Thema weil ich sag mal diese diese
russischen Rohstoffe liefen auch für den
Osten Deutschlands liefen für den Westen
Deutschland seit Jahren und Jahrzehnten
und sicher
war es nicht vorher besehbar dass Putin
das Russland sehr stark unterstützt von
russischen Bevölkerung 80 Prozent
Zustimmung in ein Aggressionskrieg gegen
die Ukraine fährt übrigens schon seit
2014/15 nicht erst seit dem 24 Februar
diesen Jahres der Krimkrieg begann
bedeuten früher und Frau Wagenknecht ich
finde Sanktionen gehören dazu man kann
nicht die Vergewaltigung von Frauen in
Ukraine tolerieren man kann Butcher
nicht tolerieren man kann nicht die
zwangsdimplantation von Kindern
ignorieren und man kann auch nicht die
Zerstörung der zivilstruktur ignorieren
also wenn man wenn man wie sie
argumentiert dann sagt sich Putin doch
ich habe alles richtig gemacht ganz im
gegen nein doch das geht schon auch
darum nicht Verbrechen aber wir ändern
daran nicht doch durch die Sanktionen
sind ja höher als vorher das geht doch
nicht nur um die Einnahmen es geht auch
darum es ist doch eine dieser große
russische Staat muss sich
minderwertige Drohnen aus dem Iran
einkaufen weil sie selber nicht in der
Lage sind sowas zu produzieren und und
und und Zustand der russischen armeeern
das wirkt schon aus meiner Sicht die
Sanktionen und kommen noch den
Ausgangspunkt zurück was Amerika
betrifft ich finde ja wir müssen eigene
und wo es möglich ist auch europäische
Interessen gemeinsam wahrnehmen wenn ich
zum Rohstoffbereich komme dann müssen
wir auch mal über unseren eigenen
Schatten springen beginnend beim Kies
und sandtagebau angefangen bis hin zu
seltenen Erden wir haben Seltene Erden
in Deutschland zum Beispiel Lithium dann
müssen wir daran gehen die selber zu
erschließen und nicht nur von chinons
abhängig zu machen und auch vom Erdgas
und Erdbeben wir einmal bei dem Vorwurf
damit Frau Wagenknecht darauf auch
antworten kann sie haben ja eigentlich
unterstellt das Frau Wagenknecht mit
ihrer These die Vergewaltigung butschter
und Co tolerieren würde ich habe ehrlich
gesagt
dann dann würde das Putin das auffassen
nee das habe ich so immer vorsichtig
diese Verbrechen dieses Krieges klar
verurteilen ich finde auch dass wir viel
mehr tun müssten um diesen Krieg auf
diplomatischen Weg zu beenden und damit
natürlich auch das Sterben und das
Leiden zu beenden das ist überhaupt
nicht die Frage die Frage ist ob diese
Sanktion irgendein sinnvollen Beitrag
dazu leisten das sehe ich nicht und ich
meine meine Kollegin sehr wem dadelen
hat vor kurzem die Bundesregierung
gefragt ob sie irgendwelche belastbaren
Erkenntnisse hat dass die Sanktionen
einen Einfluss auf den Kriegsverlauf
haben und die Antwort der
Bundesregierung war ganz knapp nein wir
haben keine Erkenntnisse ja man kann
doch nicht riesige Sanktionen die uns
selber massiv Schaden aufrechterhalten
ohne irgendwie ein Argument zu haben
dass es den Kriegsverlauf und die
Verbrechen bei dem Krieg auch nur
beeinflusst und das zweite was ich dazu
sagen will ich finde auch die
Doppelmoral heuchlerisch also es ist ja
nicht so dass wir auf alle
verbrecherischen Kriege dieser Welt mit
solchen Sanktionen reagieren Herr Habeck
fährt in den Nahen Osten herr Scholz
während den Nahen Osten nach
Saudi-Arabien wo also ein seit Jahren
ein furchtbarer verbrecherischer Krieg
gegen den je geführt wird mit ganz viel
zivilen Opfern das ist weiter weg als
die Ukraine aber das ist für die
Menschen die dort Leiden das 80.000
Kinder bisher umgebracht worden für die
Menschen die darunter leiden ist das
genauso schlimm und da machen wir keine
Sanktion da liefern wir sogar Waffen was
ich nun tatsächlich natürlich für
Russland nicht befürworten würde also
wir sollten natürlich Russland keine
Waffen und keine Drohnen liefern aber
Sanktionen für Düngemittel Sanktionen
für Getreide Sanktionen für Energie auch
für Öl Ende des Jahres hören wir auf
russisches Öl zu kaufen nach Herrn
harbecks Logik oder nach seiner
Entscheidung es ist völlig irre und
damit haben wir auch provoziert dass wir
vom Gas eben abgeklemmt wurden andere
europäische Länder kaufen russisches Gas
übrigens anders als wir also wir sind da
auch besonders dumm und das halte ich
weder von vor dem Gesichtspunkt der
Moralen noch vor irgendwelchen anderen
Kriterien für gerechtfertigt aber sind
die Deutschen Sanktionen zielführend
einmal sie haben machen wir ich
unterstütze die Sanktionen zum einen
weil ich es aus moralischer Sicht
absolut wichtig finde dass Putin etwas
entgegen gehalten wird und was wir sehen
ist ein Verhalten was man einfach nicht
tolerieren kann deswegen erstens aus
moralischer Sicht unterstütze ich die
Sanktion zweitens ich unterstütze dass
sie im europäischen Verbund verhängt
werden und mit unseren Partnern zusammen
also mit den USA und anderen westlichen
Ländern dadurch werden sie auch mehr
Schlagkraft entwickeln dritter Punkt
warum sie noch nicht den Kriegsverlauf
massiv geändert haben ist weil wir bei
bestimmten Bereichen einfach auch nicht
schnell genug waren mit den Sanktionen
und das ist nun mal gerade Öl und ist
nun mal Gas und warum wir da nicht
schneller waren ist weil das eben auch
hohe Kosten für uns verursacht und man
da eine Transition vornehmen muss und
weil andere europäische
EU-Mitgliedstaaten teilweise sogar noch
abhängiger sind und die Abstimmung im
europäischen Verbund hat uns eben an
dieser Stelle etwas langsamer gemacht
aber ist meiner Meinung nach absolut
notwendig und die Beratung da Sanktionen
von einem Tag auf den anderen greifen
das so schnell funktioniert es eben auch
nicht aber deswegen würde ich trotzdem
nicht sagen dass es falsch ist und ich
würde auch sagen letzter Punkt vierter
Punkt dass dass wir auch einen Preis
bereit sein müssen zu zahlen dafür
nämlich einen Preis um unsere Freiheit
und unsere Werte zu verteidigen denn die
Frage ist doch wirklich wo macht Putin
dein letztendlich halt wird er wirklich
bei der Ukraine halt machen oder steht
da als nächstes wer steht denn als
nächstes dann auf seiner angriffsliste
und dem muss man eben etwas
entgegenhalten aber Sanktionen alleine
reichen natürlich nicht aus man muss
weiterhin also man muss auch harte
Waffen liefern das ist auch klar an die
Ukraine und man muss trotzdem auch bei
aller bei aller Härte auch immer die
Gesprächsbereitschaft offen halten aber
im Moment ist da nichts zu sprechen im
Moment geht das nicht und deswegen eben
Sanktionen und Waffenlieferungen an die
ukrainewelt würden sie gehen wenn ich
einmal zusammenfassen aber sie sagen die
wir brauchen einfach noch länger Zeit zu
wirken wenn sie vorher beschlossen
werden wenn hätten sie schon gewirkt und
das zweite ist aufgrund der Moral aber
muss nicht den deutschen Volk auch
gegenüber die Moral gezeigt werden dass
die Sanktion auch etwas bringen also
gibt es nicht eine Pflicht der Politik
zu zeigen das und das und das und das
bringt der Verzicht bei nur zu sagen die
Moral muss es richten das reicht den
Bürgern ja anscheinend nicht mehr auch
wenn man auf im Umfragen blickt man muss
auf jeden Fall immer erklären was man
macht das ist klar und wofür was auch
machen nämlich für unsere Freiheit und
unsere Werte und dass diese auch zu
verteidigen also verteidigt werden
müssen und wir müssen auch erklären was
die Ukraine im Moment gerade auch für
uns leisten und auch dass es irgendwann
auch darum gehen wird den Wiederaufbau
mit zu finanzieren und auch das wird uns
kosten und das ist richtig dass es uns
was kostet also es braucht einen
letztendlich Marshallplan für die
Ukraine auch und das muss man erklären
natürlich klar da muss man in den
Austausch gehen also ich kann und will
zu den Sanktionen können wir nichts
sagen aus dem Handwerk weil wir einfach
da denke ich zu wenig Durchblick haben
was wirklich wie viel hilft oder nicht
aber was schon so ist ich höre immer
zahlen und man soll bereit sein zu
zahlen
wer bezahlt denn die ganzen Steuern wer
erwirtschaftet das alles das ist die
Wirtschaft und das sind vor allem die
KMU da sind die kleinen und
mittelständigen Unternehmen das sind
irgendwie glaube ich knapp 70 Prozent in
Deutschland für verantwortlich das
Steuern gezahlt werden und die sollen
gar nicht entlastet werden die sollen
genauso entlastet werden wie der
Privathaushalt da werden Äpfel mit
Birnen verglichen und es ist letzten
Endes egal wie wir im nächsten Jahr
klarkommen der Bundeskanzler hat
mehrfach gesagt er lässt niemanden
alleine kein Unternehmen alleine er weiß
um unsere um unsere Sache er weiß wie es
uns geht und nicht nur den Bäcker wie
gesagt ich betone das immer wieder wir
sind extrem energieintensiv wir sind
aber auch extrem personalintensiv es
geht um viele viele viele tausende
Arbeitsplätze und was nützt das alles
wenn wir moralisch sind aber wir heißen
unsere Wirtschaft und das wird gerade
also so kommt es bei uns gerade an dass
das passiert weil wir spüren keine
Entlastung ich habe einen Kollegen der
zahlt jeden Monat statt
6.75.000 Euro für Gas Abschläge sonst
wird ihm das abgedreht wer hilft ihm
niemand es gibt nicht ein Förderpaket
nichts und von heute auf morgen muss
bestimmt keiner Sanktionen wirken aber
vielleicht sollte langsam mal von heute
auf morgen einen Entlastung wirken weil
die ist einfach nicht da und wenn die
Betriebe dann reihenweise wenn wir uns
nicht wehren würden schließen weil wir
einfach nicht wie Herr Habeck das
vorgeschlagen hat mal ein paar Monate
nicht produzieren können das geht
einfach nicht außer er bezahlt uns
diesen Urlaub den wir dann hätten und
das wird er wohl auch nicht machen also
muss doch endlich mal gehandelt werden
und es dauert alles viel viel zu lange
wir reden jetzt wir massiv aus der Basis
reden seit acht Wochen unser
Zentralverband redet seit Mai und sie
wissen um die Dinge aber es passiert
nichts es passiert einfach nichts und
Geld muss da sein wenn für alles andere
Geld da ist und ich will nicht wissen
will mir das nicht Phasen wie viel
Steuereinnahmen mehr da sind durch die
Inflation warum werden wir nicht
entlastet und zwar schnell es gibt
nichts also die 300 Euro die die
Privathaushalte bekommen haben die
helfen uns gar nichts also fakt ist wir
sind alleine die Blaupause finde ich da
und zwar zu Beginn der corona-pandemie
die Soforthilfen die sind innerhalb von
wenigen Wochen aus dem Boden gestanden
die ersten Abschläge gab es auch relativ
schnell ja danach war riesen Theater
Missbrauch aber gleichwohl ich denke auf
die auf dieser Basis das hätte man dann
später gegenrechnen können man hat sich
erst schon wie gasumlage gestritten die
gaspreisbremsen Expertenkommission
überlassen und ich bin an der Stelle
völlig bei ihnen ich höre das auch aus
meinem freundes- und Bekanntenkreis
teilweise kriegst du ja gar kein
gasversorgungsvertrag mehr richtig das
ist also das heißt dann kannst du ja
Tschüss sagen kannst du die die Bude
dicht machen und da hilft auch keine
aufgemotztes Kurzarbeitergeld dann
dieser Stelle also nochmal ich finde die
Blaupausen sind da da muss man sich auch
nicht zwingend ständig an der
eu-beihilfe recht stören ich finde dann
muss man einfach machen an der Stelle
und die Dinge kann man dann später
Regeln ich kann mich noch gut erinnern
wie Olaf Scholz da ständig rumgetutet
hat zu coronazeit und Peter Altmaier an
die Wand gedrückt hat aber ich muss
sagen diese ampeltruppe die bastelt oder
sie weiß es eigentlich seit dem 24
Februar
2022 und das auf Sanktionen Putin das
Gas abdreht das war erwartbar aus meiner
Sicht also insoweit ja zwischen Februar
und heute das ist ein Dreivierteljahr
gemacht andere europäische Länder da
gibt es längst gaspreisdeckel da gibt es
längst strompreisdeckel da ist es
natürlich etwas abgemildert und ich
finde auch also es muss dringend was
getan werden ganz kurzfristig und ganz
schnell und damit die Unternehmen nicht
tot sind weil ich meine habex Idee man
macht mal Urlaub eine Weile und dann
kommt mal wieder ist eben wirklich
sehr kreativ und eben ja ein typischer
Habig aber das Grundproblem bleibt
natürlich trotzdem und das ist der
Unterschied zur corona-zeit die
corona-zeit da haben wir viel
idiotisches gemacht aber es war
zumindest immer klar es ist ein
überschaubarer Zeitraum ein Lockdown war
ein überschaubarer Zeitraum danach war
klar
2020 Gramm sorry
was anderes hinaus ich will und darauf
hinaus das ist natürlich irgendwann
ich will darauf hinaus dass es trotzdem
zu corona-zeiten klar war irgendwann ist
es wieder normal irgendwann macht man
wieder auf und wir brauchen die
Perspektive natürlich auch bei den
Energiepreisen also natürlich kann man
kurzfristig und muss man jetzt mit
staatlichem Geld da subventionieren und
unterstützen aber wir müssen ja auch
immer Bedenken auch das staatliche Geld
was dort eingesetzt wird ist das
Steuergeld was die Menschen aufbringen
also das ist natürlich auch regeltasche
Rechte Klasse
und erstmal sind sehr gut aber den
nächsten 20 Jahren nur Schulden machen
also irgendwann irgendwann
garantiert nicht wir müssen natürlich
gebracht werden in den Griff kriegen wir
können nicht auf Dauer subventionieren
das mache ich damit auch die Einigkeit
gerade ganz schön Handlungsbedarf
Handlungsbedarf Handlungsbedarf selten
nach einer These über Russland und
Ukraine so viel Einigkeit am